so this question of intelligence is
really interesting and I think very
important because you know we talk about
intelligence as if we know what it is
right but we don't it expresses itself
in so many itself in so many different
ways there's so many manifestations so
this big controversy that's happening
now among you know between I don't know
if you're aware this was Sam Harris and
Ezra Klein and Andrew Sullivan and
people are trying to marry Charles
Murray
right exactly that whole thing about
people that don't know what the weather
is so they're charles Murray wrote this
book called the bell curve I don't know
20 years ago or something 25 even yeah
where he argued that there are racial
differences in intelligence IQ
specifically with Asians being the
highest and then whites and then blacks
and that that's just the way it is and
social adjustments aren't going to
change that because it's largely genetic
Ryan and you know that's as I understand
that was the argument I haven't I don't
think it's saying largely genetic but I
think they're saying that genetics play
a factor and environment plays a factor
I think some people are not willing to
look at genetics if it shows an
unfavorable trait in minorities they
just they don't want to look at it they
yeah they do not true but I think it's
also true that part of the argument is
that social programs are a waste of
money cuz they're not going to affect it
because its genetic that's crazy like
that I'm very sure the argument that's
just straight racist to me well I think
that's what people are the ideal accept
your money to save your money know do a
better job like you don't even know if
it works because what have you done
like what go to the inner city school
right and pretend you're a ten year old
kid trying to get by in this life and
you're literally seeing gang members and
craziness and people flashing cash and
people dropping out because they're
pregnant when they're 13 and you're
trying to tell me this not there's not
some sort of a massive environmental
factor if you were a white kid yeah
going to a school like that I only went
to a bad school for one year of my life
I'm not I'm no og
but I really did go to one bad school
Mary Curley middle school in Jamaica
Plain and the Jamaica Plain
Massachusetts it's now it's become
gentrified sort of it's kind of like
East LA or silver a silver lake area you
know like a lot of hipsters have moved
in and nice and places but when I lived
there it was not good it was very poor
people and the the [ __ ] middle school
was scary it was scary seventeen year
old kids my seventh grade class no one
it was just a weird play maybe I guess
it was eighth grade but the point was
these kids were they were never gonna
graduate they knew it and they were
trying to go back to seventh grade again
or eighth grade whatever the [ __ ] it was
and the teacher would have them in the
class for a couple days and then they
would leave and everywhere you walked
you were scared
everywhere you walked like some weird
[ __ ] was happening with people people
were yelling at people there was always
like tension and there was always like
bigger kids around that were robbing
other kids like yeah like I got through
that year going holy [ __ ] and when I got
out of there my parents moved I moved to
a really nice part of town Newton but if
you're a kid growing up in that
environment good [ __ ] luck learning
anything good finding probably it's it's
pretty bad at home too
yeah and what I experienced in Jamaica
Plain was nothing compared to Dorchester
and Roxbury those are the bad areas yeah
they were way worse and we know that
anxiety stress stops brain develop yes
[ __ ] yes it also makes people much
more inclined to violence yeah you know
sure and you're when you grow up in them
even in the womb if your mother's around
horrible situations and people screaming
and fighting and yeah that cortisol and
adrenaline and all those all those
hormones are flowing through that baby
preparing that baby for a violent world
well then you I'm sure you know about
the epigenetics that show that that can
pass several generations yes grandfather
was in a famine you're more likely to be
obese not crazy it's not yeah